- We've got SNL cast
member, Aidy Bryant on set,
give it up!
(audience cheering)
So we are all used to Skype, Zoom
and FaceTime these days.
If you're not, then you've
been really isolated,
but we're even used to all
the technical issues that
usually come with it, as well,
like when I was talking to "Bones"
and "Seal Team" actor,
David Boreanaz this summer
and this happened.
- You can't hear me?
- I wish, I can't hear you,
but I wish I could read lips,
but I can't.
I'll put Louie down.
- Okay.
Navy SEAL.
Navy.
- No.
- SEAL.
- This is like a game.
Sounds like shirt, okay.
- You play.
- Yes, "SEAL Team."
- Yes!
- Yep, that was a lot
of the interview, folks.
So, now in honor of Aidy's
show "Shrill" on Hulu,
it's time to put both our mics on mute
and play the David Boreanaz
Can't Hear Me Game.
♪ The David Boreanaz Can't Hear Me Game ♪
(Kelly laughing)
I love you, Jessie.
How competitive do you
get on game nights, Aidy?
Are you like all in?
- I am the opposite where
I'm like, "You win, I lose."
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
- But today I'm gonna really go for it.
- We are, we could not be more opposite,
so that's fine, we're gonna be playing
for the audience.
We're not going against each other.
Just kidding.
So this is a virtual version
of the old 19th century game Charades.
Aidy and I take turns trying
to get the other to say a word or phrase
while our mics are muted.
We're allowed to say the words,
use motions and use props.
If we want to pass, we
hold up our pass card.
If we can get a total
of eight words correct
in two rounds, everyone in the house seats
will win a prize, so, okay.
Mute my mic and I'll go
first, are you ready.
Go!
- Oh, ice cream.
- Ice cream cone.
(bell ringing)
Yes.
"Baby Shark," "Baby Shark,"
"Baby Shark" doo doo doo doo doo.
A beautiful hair.
A hair extension.
(bell ringing)
A hair.
Oh, brushing your teeth.
A toothbrush.
(bell ringing)
- Okay, so Aidy's giving
the clues this time,
so mute her mic and let's go.
Here we go.
Corn on the cob, oh, flossing,
flossing, dental floss.
(bell ringing)
Phone number, calling.
Phone call.
Answer the phone.
iPhone? iPhone?
(dramatic music)
Paper, paper.
Cutting paper.
Cutting paper cut, paper cut.
Staple, staple paper, stapling paper.
Fudge.
Snapping paper.
Paper clip.
(bell ringing)
Paper clip!
Remote.
(bell ringing)
We won, we won, we won, we did it, whoo!
We're amazing, so for game nights,
we should be a team.
All right, we did it,
so everybody in our
house seats is a winner.
Ber, ber, ber, ber.
The Globber E10 electric scooters
are equipped with high quality components
and smart features to deliver safe
and intuitive eScooter rides
and they're easy to use, user friendly
and have a built-in dual braking system.
In celebration of National Scooter Day
on May 19th, you're all getting
a Globber E10 electric scooter.
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much, Aidy,
I love you so much.
Season three of "Shrill" is now streaming
on Hulu everybody.